We're excited to announce
Google's new Startup Launch
program.
Our mission is to help
startups worldwide become
successful on the Google
Developers platform
and over open
source technologies.
Startup Launch gives you all
of the tools and insights
you need all in one place.
As a developer, it takes
a lot to build your app
and grow your business.
But putting the
usual list aside,
there's something more that
you might need-- a supportive
community built just
for you, an empowering
environment with global
events, supportive colleagues
and friends who
are here for you.
Learn everything
you need to know
about developing a great
app with free mentorships
and online training.
Grow with UX reviews
from our team of mentors.
And take advantage
of early access
to upcoming APIs, SDKs,
and product releases.
With the right monetization and
distribution tools from Google,
you can rest easy while
your app continues to grow.
Startup Launch is
already helping thousands
of entrepreneurs like you
in over 100 countries.
To give your business a
chance to be everything
you know it can be, apply
to Startup Launch today.
Visit
developers.google.com/startups
for all the info.